so I'm Robertson I'm the Dean of the
school and I want to welcome you all to
a constructed world which is the seventh
J Irwin Miller symposium it is supported
by an endowment established in 2010
through the generosity of mr. Miller's
children katherine margaret elizabeth
and will I'm deeply grateful to the
Miller family for choosing the honor the
memory of their father through this
partnership with the School of
Architecture allowing us to have
scholarly symposia on a regular basis
such as the one we are opening tonight a
word about jr. when Miller is
appropriate he was in 1931 Phi Beta
Kappa graduate of Yale College as an
undergraduate his major subjects were
Greek and Latin after Yale he continued
his education at Oxford University where
he studied philosophy politics and
economics at Balliol College in 1934 mr.
Miller began his professional career
with the family business Cummins engine
company ultimately serving as president
and chairman during World War two mr.
Miller saw active duty as a new to
lieutenant in the US Navy in the South
Pacific mr. Miller was one in a million
and I was privileged to know him at the
end of his life a successful businessman
a pillar of his torch a loyal alumnus of
Yale who served his corporation fellow
from nineteen fifty nine to nineteen
seventy seven and he was a fierce
advocate for freedom of choice for
everyone an opportunity for all his
great respect for the power of
architecture to improve the public realm
is reflected in the program of patronage
he established in his home city of
columbus indiana where many architects
were of first-rate quality were invited
to design at the expense of the commons
foundation buildings in the public realm
from City Hall's hospitals to schools
and in pub and religious institutions he
was a man of great curiosity and an
outstanding citizen second to none the
embodiment of ethical behavior a model
for us all before introducing tonight's
lecturers I would like to express my
appreciation to the very many who helped
make this weekend's events possible I
should say in anticipation the smooth
running of this weekend's events I want
to thank Richard to flummery and Robbie
lennar noi our schools special events
coordinators and associate dean John
Jacobson who is also doubling this
weekend as our school photographer each
of whom has contributed mightily
mightily to this event special thanks
are also in order for the exceptional
work performed by our schools exhibition
staff director of exhibitions alpha
coder 1900 2011 graduate of art school
and exhibitions coordinator in gallery
registrar Alison Walshe let a crack
installation team including recent
graduates and current students to
prepare for the amazing exhibition you
will see after the lecture in the in the
gallery in 2013 the product project city
of 7 billion was the recipient of the
American Institute of Architects
prestigious latrobe prize for research
reading to the exhibit in our gallery
which is also supported by our schools
Heinz Research Fund for the advance for
advanced sustainability in architecture
it has also received support from the
Graham foundations in the Advanced
Studies in the fine arts from Thomas &
Barrel zhang jie natsu and kelly clark
pelle architects on behalf of the School
of Architecture I extend my sincere
appreciation to all those whose
generosity has enabled this exhibit and
some
him to take place it's now my pleasure
to introduce this evenings speakers
Joyce Zhang and boom all Mendes whom I
commend for their scholarship
imaginative path-breaking exhibit design
and tireless work in convening the
symposium they are wonderful colleagues
to each of us on the faculty in this
school George song received her Bachelor
of Arts from Yale in 1999 and her Master
of Architecture from our school in 2003
following her studies at Yale Joyce
worked in the New Haven office of pelli
clarke belly and then in rotterdam
office of metropolitan architecture
before returning to her new haven and
co-founding in 2007 the firm plan B
architecture and urbanism there is no
plan a by the way
to my knowledge risk Joyce has combined
professional practice with teaching at
Yale and was recently appointed an
assistant dean in art school the
momentous like Dean shown his co partner
at plan b architecture and urbanism
holds to Yale degrees he received his BA
in 1998 and his master of architecture
in 2002 as well he worked in the New
Haven office of pelli clarke belly and
at oma and rotterdam you think there's a
pattern there and now combines
professional practice was teaching in
our school which he serves as assistant
dean director of undergraduate studies
and assistant professor adjunct please
join me in welcoming to the podium joy
Chang and Gamal Mendes as they deliver
the lecture city of 7 billion the
opening address to the 7th j irwin
miller symposium a constructed world
joyce MP mall
thank you all there are very few moments
in one's lives when we get to stand and
talk to so many people the people who
have taught us the people we work with
the people we have admired from afar and
people we admire very closely that we
know very dearly so many of who are so
open and interested in what we care
deeply about and we are even more
honored and overwhelmed by how receptive
all of our distinguished guests have
been to be willing to reframe their work
through ways in which the world is
constructed and deconstructed and moving
forward to register the wealth of
important ideas discussed this weekend
many that have already been so formative
in our continuing work and respective
lives as anthropologists economists
historians artists educators and
students I hope that the weekend will
leave us all seeing the world one's work
the things we do in a different way I
know that we will and so we say thank
you to all yes thank you working the
exhibition primarily models and drawings
represents the way we approach our
curiosities and questions many of them
quite simple or innocently asked to
explore and discover new problems to
that end we always saw the exhibition in
conjunction with the symposium as a
project itself while the city of 7
billion the constructed world suggest a
framework of looking at the world as one
city as a construct identity this
project was just as much a framework for
an exhibition and the accompanying that
symposium and its conversations the
collective experience and this is very
important to us becomes a very important
platform for our research and research
as a medium and we are especially
grateful for Yale for allowing us to
create this environment for discovery
and education tonight you want to share
some some of our stories and discoveries
they're really more I guess constructed
anecdotes more than a formal
presentation to say and talk about the
work that's upstairs and confess these
and explore some of the challenges we've
had along the way and also so that you
can seek your own kind of disco
from observing these their fables about
May twenty-third 2007 when a woman left
fields entered the city of Suzhou or
maybe Bangalore and single-handedly
tilted humanity toward an urban majority
you may remember this moment not so long
ago being greeted each morning with
breaking news headlines confidently
proclaiming things like world population
becomes more urban than rural urban
populations becoming the new majority
worldwide as if it were some kind of
political party rural reaches urban
tipping point as if it were a social
trend or a little more poetically the
world goes to town these stories began
with a sense of immediacy with phrases
like for the first time ever or last
week or sometimes more hesitantly by
next year or even soon there are often
pictures to illustrate these stories
again the image of a woman walking
through the fields towards a city or
maybe it was these four men riding
camels at the end of a long journey
leaving the sands of the desert and
their nomadic lifestyles behind to enter
the city a new horizon of opportunities
or so we were told and the authors such
as the United Nations the source for the
story in this case lent credibility we
personally were captivated but also
skeptical skeptical of these fables of
one woman in the fields or one man on a
camel single-handedly tipping the scales
of humankind toward an urban majority
such fabrications are entertaining at
best buy deceptive at worst when they
invoke the spurious urban-rural divide
what is this divide where does rural and
an urban start how can one even begin to
define urban versus rural this great
shift from a rural to urban majority is
often cited yet completely opaque one
approach yields and ever widening terms
to describe this urban phenomenon
conurbation
domination metropolis humanopolis the
endless city and on it goes another
approach the statistical definition of
urban by the UN in this case the author
of that report confuses in mangles
definitions by municipality region and
nation is it 100 people per square
kilometer 400 people per square
kilometer contiguous built area greater
than 5,000 people greater than 2500
people places with essential services
places in certain cases something very
specific as determined by the department
of town planning and housing of ministry
every district with a municipality some
places even name male for example the
capital that's an urban area so it's
interesting for us to think about these
but ultimately the scale and scope of
urbanization has tested transgressed and
ultimately dissolve traditional
boundaries is not every peak plane or
recess layer we inhabit urban the
holding in some way to cultivation
extraction quantification
industrialization surveillance and
contamination consider then another
fable rather an allegorical painting to
be precise that imagines the urban and
rural divide which might be ingrained in
our collective conscience or memory
ambrosio Lorenzo T's fresco the allegory
of good and bad government which is
painted in the Palazzo publico in Siena
in the 13th century shown here on first
impression the divide is quite literally
a wall and there seems to be little
ambiguity between where the city ends
and the countryside begins between what
is considered urban and rural yet on
closer inspection the city and the
country are inseparable the virtues and
vices that are contained within the
walls of the city spill out onto the
landscape that's supported as things
flow seamlessly back and forth under
good government the landscape shown here
is fertile and productive as far as the
eye can see nourishing the city and
allowing it to thrive but under bad
government the city and Congress that
are both for
falling into ruin the fields unplowed
and ablaze with conflict today the city
scour the countryside for resources it
must consume no part is immune they're
completely inseparable how then should
be regard yet another third form of
iconography on the city the large
self-assured models like those of Robert
Moses New York confidently appropriated
here by Mayor Bloomberg Benito
Mussolini's Rome both of them Shanghai
or London such models were made to
convey certainty and control completely
isolated from their surroundings these
models were and continue to be
propaganda for the city and its makers
defining their limits and exuding a
false sense of stability and what if
instead we considered why it means to be
urban in terms of all its people
wherever they might be and not in terms
of walls limits or boundaries what if
the fundamental building block of the
city was quite literally the individuals
that comprise it could we not understand
urbanization as a topography of people
aggregating and accumulating over time
all seven billion of us and the billions
before that is the world as a city of
people figures and grounds unfolds from
the uncertainty of global sprawl it
accepts instability of urbanization and
privileges people over land using a
cartographic projection developed by our
Buckminster Fuller the model unfolds the
surface of the earth across the North
Pole as shown here instead of using the
conventional boundary of a country or
continent as an edge the model uses the
exclusive economic zone or easy as it is
more commonly known the ultimate limit
of territorial control this is the zone
where nations territorial waters extend
200 miles into the ocean outside this
boundary international waters and
throughout questions of who is in
control
taken together this zone fuses the
world's land masses into a single
contiguous site a supercontinent
extruded pixels index past present and
future population figures 1800 1900 2000
projections for 2050 over a topography
that is just as volatile at the
demographic data that pile on top of it
each pixel is a 30-kilometer by 30
kilometre plot of land each centimeter
in height a density of 100 people per
square kilometer or 90,000 people for us
our project the city of 7 billion is not
simply a proposition it's a reflection
of an unrelenting reality the resulting
topography is a continuity of people a
model of us and yet we are not in
control
to prove another question like the
urban-rural divide we also found the
term footprint the footprint of a city
the footprint of urbanization just as
unsettling with a footprint you're bound
to the ground you're left the impression
that a city organization must also be
bound to the ground imprinted into the
earth two dimensional horizontal
spreading sprawling moving laterally a
closed figure a plan based area but
aren't the extensive urbanization beyond
to be mention all consider that on any
given day 8 million people a number
equal to the population of New York City
inhabit the atmosphere as they sit or
sleep each or tweet aboard tens of
thousands of aircraft six miles above
the Earth's crust with three billion
inhabitants a year is this not our
transient city in the sky and perhaps
you can see it the city versity in this
image it is a satellite image from NASA
one of many you can easily find online
it shows one morning in january 2004
although it could be any morning
actually receive patterns of
condensation left in the wake of
airplanes flying over the southeastern
part of the United States these patterns
traces of our vertical habitation
crisscrossing spreading dissolving into
the sky form a fleeting figure of a city
in the sky almost baroque and hovering
over the hidden Jeffersonian grid below
in ancient world the user sky was an
airy or infinite much solid and finite a
rigid substance vast solid dome tangible
and firm today this firmament is carved
into diverse strata of occupation and
control commercial aircraft at six miles
above sea level stealth aircraft at 12
miles weather balloons at 25 miles that
somehow escaped this drawing space
stations and shuttles between 200 400
miles and low orbit and high orbit
satellites anywhere between 400 miles
and 22,000 miles perhaps we increasingly
operate along a vertical gradient of
urbanization a volume rather than an
area
what then are the limits of this
volumetric City if not the boundary of a
footprint a city wall or the urban-rural
divide you might say the common line
it's at an altitude of 62 miles above
sea level in the dotted line that you
can see above the section of the Earth's
crust the internationally accepted
boundary between the earth's atmosphere
and outer space the ultimate edge of the
world and yet we transgress this
frontier time and time again our
terrestrial world is tethered to a dense
swarm of devices the fixtures of a city
whose edges extend far beyond the
outermost threshold of the atmosphere
the city thickens in varying and
shifting vertical gradients plunging
into oceans and reaching into outer
space perhaps the city is now bigger
than the world itself and is this the
side plan of our city question with
asking perhaps what is a vantage point
then that we get from this increasingly
strada or increasingly higher strata
that we occupy further and further away
from the Earth's crust scenes from the
horizon shown here which occupies the
perimeter of the gallery captures life
on Earth in panorama from one horizon
looking to it another technologies and
that enable us to occupy the skies also
afford us the vantage points from which
to witness how we are transforming the
surface below the long and deep Vista
reveals that the city of 7 billion
permeates through land water air and out
of space signs of human life not human
figures are everywhere present so this
is the sort of director's cut version of
the evening where we just wanted to give
you some of the background some of the
things that we were thinking about when
we when we made this and one of the
things that always impressed upon us is
you know who are we in this view what
does it mean to be looking at the world
as a satellite or drone or somebody
sitting behind Google Earth and what
those kinds of implications as we look
to the urbanization of space the
urbanization of the atmosphere and the
urbanization of oceans there are things
that we are doing that we are just sort
of maybe exploring about these ideas of
urbanization and landscape and and some
of the things that we're sort of playing
with and hiding in here this is sort of
one scene where we always saw this as if
it looked as if it were a kind of
sunrise you imagine looking from outer
space that it would be a sunrise but in
a way we sort of had termed this in the
office the kind of nuclear John it's a
kind of view looking over the area of
the South Pacific we're post-war all of
the kind of nuclear test sites were
occurring and this of course is one of
the many sites or potential discussions
about when the Anthropocene did begin
the anthers between being the era when
the world is profoundly perhaps
irrevocably transformed by human
activity rendering all seven billion of
us and the bill is before us as the
Earth's designers and constructors so
it's this kind of game where we were
sort of hiding these little stories
within a little bit like having these
hidden moments where as you scroll
through google earth I'm sure all you
have done this and you come across a
weird building the desert and you think
to yourself what's going on there and so
you know these views also look at for
example the urbanization the ocean hear
things like the exclusive economic zone
to see where we are having where there
are kinds of territorial boundaries
coming across here this is a kind of
scene I guess we'll we'll uncover the
sea in which we're kind of to expose the
anatomy of a drawing in a way I'm part
of this is knowing how often the images
that we see of the earth are so
constructed pieced together 5-10 years
of Google Earth images things that we
get used to the way they Eames do and
this is sort of our unveiling of how
this image was constructed using every
single probably computer this building
rendering the the base topography and
really exploring also a lot of things
that we look at all the time in this
case the electrical grid of the United
States the electrical networks is a
different way of thinking about the
epicenters of urbanization but through a
way that's more pictographic almost
picturesque a kind of landscape
painting as opposed to these objective
maps that we see all the time and yes in
case you're wondering we've also
exaggerated the topography it's it's
magnified by twenty-five percent below
the ocean and fifteen percent above and
that's a trick or a deceit that
cartographers have always heard
exaggeration the technical term from
what we gather but obviously you do this
to to amplify what it is that you're
looking at and in a way some of the
precedents that we were really thinking
about where more things like landscape
landscape painters or Thomas Cole who
you know we're questioning the
relationship between human kind and
nature or questions of city or
wilderness and what those edges were
because we really saw these as the ways
of looking at a new kind of wilderness
other kinds of inspirations or things
that we always return to when we thought
about this drawing was Bruegel
specifically his landscape painting of
the fall of icarus and not just bro
eagle but bro eagle by way of our din
and not just bro go by way of alden but
also bro go by way of out and by way of
demerol Alexander na graph whose
interpretation of those two works asked
what do artists and poets and critics do
in the face of catastrophe how do they
register in their work or should they
even tried to do so and it was something
also that kind of haunted us a little
bit as we were working on this I'm sort
of thought about those kinds of proverbs
the idea of an allegory about the ascent
and fall of a boy who tried to fly too
close to the Sun was always in the air
and you know literally pinned up in the
walls around us and we'd like you to
have with us and this imposed in one
person who did cross this threshold
Katherine Sullivan as a director of Noah
was an astronaut and she is perhaps the
only person who's seen this kind of
perspective that we are that we can only
create through technology but it's also
you know refers to things like the
overview effect on the question of what
it is if you get a new view of the earth
by having seen the world afar or if it's
something more insidious this is another
drawing or model
actually that strips away all of that
stuff you saw before and shows you the
path that we took across the surface of
the earth and this is another drawing
that again gets back edit a kind of
animation that traces the loop the
looping path off the panorama and if you
can imagine a tennis ball or a baseball
and and think of how its constructed as
two intersecting figures the path of
that panorama essentially praises the
seam that stitches this two pieces
together and that that then unfolds out
to become this continuous drawing that
wraps around the entire gallery in a way
I mean we what we always call this was
the panorama drawing and again it you
know it's one of many things where we
were sort of constructing and
deconstructing the world in this case
flattening finding a path and seeing how
you sort of strip of you and turn it
inside out to create this immersive ring
another kind of story the first time we
learned about cornelli globes was
through the notes italo calvino wrote on
his visit to the 1980 exhibition carte
de figure de la terre maps in figures of
the earth at the Pompidou to quote
Calvino two gigantic spheres each 12
meters in circumference a globe of the
earth and one of the sky are the high
point of the exhibition and occupied the
whole of the forum of the Pompidou
Center these are the largest globes ever
constructed and were commissioned by
louis the 14th from a francese
franciscan monk from venice Vincenzo
cornelli the great Marvel is the earthly
globe in dark brown and ochre colors
after this and there are other reasons
but certainly after this and reading
reading what Calvino said we definitely
wanted to make a sphere and not just any
sphere but a big one larger than life
floating but also within reach we sensed
a degree of Nessus necessity in this but
that we really could not fully
articulate but we also confessed
it really was just the thrill of the
challenge the sheer scale a geometrical
exercise figuring out something that was
difficult and we were also egged on by
unofficial research assistant the ever
resourceful Dean stern from whom we
would periodically find notes like these
in our mailboxes usually 11 a week and
who knew that we could have made these
turns fear obsessed the sphere
continuous whole external tricks the
viewer into registering completeness and
yet its form always defeats the viewer
who must constantly rotate around it
each of you changing with each vantage
point a complete picture always remains
elusive around 1898 the French
geographer a clue called for a new
science geography to counter the
popularity of mapmaking quoting ray clue
new globes must be temples themselves as
well by the magnificence of proportions
as by the beauty of workmanship in the
scrupulous care of scientific drawing he
continues there's only one way to
represent truly the surface of the earth
kurz are to be translated in curves a
sphere or fragment of a sphere must be
reproduced by another sphere or fragment
of sphere it was precisely this
observation by Riku that compelled us to
make a globe and our curiosity
approached the making of a sphere as a
kind of intellectual an object of
intellectual pursuit why a globe what
could one learn from make the making of
a sphere itself one thought was well why
not it was pretty simple as that but if
only it was that simple so if flattening
the sphere has a rich ricci documented
legacy of cartographic projections the
construction of a sphere was very
ography azra clue cold it has its own
curious dilemmas and challenges and I'm
sure you're all familiar with these
projections be sliced unwrapped one
folded cartographic approximations we
wanted what happens when you reverse
this process and try and picture for
yourself the forms they can
yield the Mercator a cylinder the fuller
technically a polyhedron or an
icosahedron depending on which
projection or to quote from the patent
buckminster fuller filed on January 29th
1946 this figure I call a Dymaxion the
alborz equal area conic a cone a cubic
projection cubed the goodie home all
seem to us that kind of looked like a
lump with seams on the other hand Martin
wall simulans projection consisting of
12 wedges or goes as they are called was
invented for the purpose of being pasted
together onto a sphere to form a small
terrestrial globe the first of its kind
first printed in 1507 the small woodcut
map 24 x 39 centimeters was also created
to be reproduced coinciding with the
invention of the Western printing press
it was a tool then for the dissemination
and democratization of knowledge for us
it provided not just a conceptual
scaffold but also a viable template for
construction and assembly our globe is
almost identical in size of the coronary
Globes and perhaps by happy coincidence
they were dictated by I wish to make the
globe and the model the same scale at
123 million and this animation or all
kind of time lapse is a reconstruction
of one day one day amongst many when we
actually installed the substructure of
the sphere in the galleria above this is
like night at the museum for us this is
what happens when i read is away on the
weekends and we literally used volte
mueller's Gore's as the medium by which
we constructed this sphere so that
became it looks a lot easier in this
video that was the Atlas moment where
everybody got tired
those two had to kind of there was a
belt put around everybody had to take a
break because it was going to class so
one thing we did learn is that spheres
are not easy to construct these process
it's a lot of shifting going on so like
waltzing Mueller's goes our plans are
moving from land to air to water so we
saw these as literally plans for the
world and this is these drawings in a
way these really are how we made the
sphere these drawings of the Gores are
literally the drawings we made in order
to construct and surfaces fear the
network of lines by which we communicate
and travel around the earth it also de
laminates some of the things embedded in
the panorama we were reminded again
above Calvino and his description of the
Pompidou exhibition the earliest need to
fix places on a map was linked to travel
it was a reminder of the succession of
stops the outline of a journey it was
thus linear in form and could only be
made using a long school in our case it
takes the form of gores 12 of them one
for each 30 degree longitudinal slice of
the earth and like Walt's Mueller vault
similar the globe the Gores were plans
for the globe moving from lowest to
highest water land air by land drawings
of the terrestrial networks were printed
cut out and applied to a giant
typographical sphere including rose
transmission lines and rail networks
maritime networks were laid down onto
our relief globe not unlike the ways
they move around the world undersea
fiber optic internet cables unspooled
and draped in copper as they are in
schooled from ships that cross the
oceans to lay down these critical
informational networks shipping lanes in
look registering sea level ephemeral
transparent airnet works wrapped and
unwrapped as a tracery mostly in our
long panorama drawing our globe charts
the pathways we make to circumscribe the
earth with drawed networks transmission
lines submarine cables shipping lanes
and air routes if we haven't traced it
we cannot know it it was captivating to
see the lines in this way so often so
abstract cutting the picture planes and
architectural drawings or simply points
that connect different pieces of data
together but here they became very human
the ways we travel communicate and get
to know the world they describe the
contours of our very existence
so these are two elevational drawings of
the world and again there's different
ways in which these lines operate and
zooming in to the topography and the
bathymetry of the world begin to see
different forms of contour is slowly
taking shape
there we go it is rare to find a
featureless map ocean chart Henry
holidays illustration for Lewis
Carroll's 1876 nonsense poem the hunting
of the snark shows the ocean as a single
blank rectangle bound on its border by
only a few mapping conventions Lewis
Carroll's perfect and absolute blank
chooses to show nothing there for
rendering itself useless for navigation
Carroll's fiction opposite to that of
the fiction found in most Maps lies in
the presumption that in many parts of
the world the surface of the earth is
populated by nothing neither landforms
nor dragons nor other identifying
features you'll find our ode to Carolyn
holiday in the exhibition we titled it G
100 general information the first and
critical drawing in our drawing set
section for the world and there are
countless stories of unresolved quests
around the globe legends of
disappearances in the Bermuda Triangle
Donald Rumsfeld's known unknowns in the
search for arcs non-existent weapons of
mass destruction or the 2014
disappearance of Malaysian Airlines
flight 370 to fall off the face of the
earth is an idiom that still resonates
early globe makers painted sea monsters
and parts of the ocean they can
approximate better to be cautious and
clueless I suppose geographical efforts
are still stamped with a caveat of the
known world we understand the earth to
the extent that we've traversed it dry
ground is continually eroded filled and
moved out dating satellite photos as
soon as they are taken and the seafloor
beyond a blurred image is as much as
ninety-nine point nine five percent
unchartered this drawing charts the
parts of the seafloor that have been
surveyed and these track lines in fact
are the roots of boats or ships that
scan the ocean floor and we see from
here the intensity of ports coastlines
the underwater seismic activity and
tectonic plates that ships tend to kind
of concentrate on and choose to navigate
around
in reality modern days photography is
merely a stitched together ball of
uneven information the sphere before you
admits its gaps and even the surfaces it
claims to know should be read with
suspicion these drawings describe the
lattices and pock marks you'll see on
the surface of our globe the unknowns of
the Earth's crust it seemed profound to
us to frame our works for the things we
don't know to foreground the unknowns
and not be fearful of them as if marked
with dragons and monsters cornelli
inscribed his great wondrous globe with
quips like hear people say there is an
island but this is false and I won't put
one here or even better I found I had a
space to fill so I inserted this caption
perhaps frame with a bit of humor
vitality certainly pleasure and
excitement might allow us to look at the
unknown on you
so the sphere was in essence the central
organizing element around for our
exhibition it was the framework upon
which three other elements organized
themselves around you begin to see in
this animation how this piece is kind of
fit together working around and in some
ways speaking to each other dissolving
dematerializing wrapping unwrapping they
are all essentially part of the same
figure but taking taking on different
shapes I think for us part of that was
because the ignition for us was always
so central to the project itself it
wasn't separate from it but in fact was
the kind of project so the framework for
some might say the framework for the
project was the city or the framework
for the project was the idea of the
Anthropocene but I think for us always
the framework of the exhibition is as
much the framework of the project the
framework of the symposium the
conversation that comes from this was as
much the project and as important in a
way and to that end I think part of that
was how what an exhibition space could
do that was distinctive or something
that you might get from a book or
something that we might see on a
computer screen or something we might
see in another kind of printed material
that would be enabled by the actual
space certainly the viewpoints that one
might get and something that was sort of
palpable and scale obviously was
something that was extraordinarily
important just because of constraints
but also in terms of how one could get
these kinds of overviews but also be
immersed in in what you're looking at
and and it was even for us a lot of the
things that we were doing and working on
you didn't know what it would look like
until it was all up there you were
always working in these different pieces
and fragments and it wasn't until it
came together that you saw what the big
picture was
so we encourage you all of course to go
upstairs and actually enjoy the
exhibition rather than looking at these
images but this one in particular is
fairly important for us it is a
topography of our symposium it's a it's
the kind of intellectual topography so
to speak a topography with ideas of all
the 26 participants that Professor Dana
Tomlin who will be moderating tomorrow's
discussion actually made and created
specifically for this and this forum
that we've created through the agency of
Dean Stewart and the school is something
that we feel is fundamentally important
to bring some of these ideas to to bear
I think a lot of these people have far
more have far more expertise and we do
in this subject and I've been doing this
for much longer and in some ways don't
even agree with some of the basic
fundamentals of premises of our research
and I think that's the whole idea of
having a symposium and bringing people
together and bringing people to one
place to talk about virgin issues that
are confronting our time so we
definitely encourage you all to attend
as many of these sessions as possible
they are kind of loosely the panel's
themselves are loosely constructed
around different processes of
construction you have surveys and
demolition excavation scaffolding
framing assemblies they are purposely
open-ended so that each of the speakers
and participants and the moderators can
formulate or shape that term in any
given direction that they want based on
their own research and work
and finally um when we see the world of
lines and you see our exhibit we
actually see people many many many
people actually we see hands and faces
often masked by dust or things we won't
mention in public but but especially we
see the curious minds of all the people
who have helped us to bring this
exhibition and symposium together
colleagues our friends people who
recalled up yesterday for example to ask
how we should frame this talk today as
much as this huge and very team that we
work with team members like Bobby Robert
Kennedy know who was an instrumental
part of this process for the last year
and a half almost who together with
Andrew rough and miroslava Brooks helped
lead a very competent and curious and
hardworking team that enabled us to do
all this and we certainly can't name all
of them that's why we fear the music
it's like Oscar but we didn't want to
thank everybody because I think this
project is very much a kind of testament
to all of the wonderful students and I
think it's sort of left its mark on
every single corner of this building
every single person and thank you
certainly to Dean Stern for being so
supportive because it is something that
I feel I think we've used every single
tool and trick in the school as well so
certainly between the digital media
Johnny bruh heart and every the shops
and Tim Newton and all of the resources
that have come together I think this
really is if anything as much a product
of all of the resources and mines and
work of all of the students that and
research assistants have been part there
so we are very grateful and thankful for
that Thank you Thank
thank you so that was what was going on
all thank you very much I'm sure I'm
there we have a little time for some
questions and it's appropriate for those
of you who are visitors here you know
that we do have Q&A at the end of some
speeches and we need to bring a mic down
a Kent bloomer has this hand up yes that
glue I congratulate you for a
extraordinary accomplishment and the
construction that Club the the question
I'm asking is why did you choose to
leave at monochrome as a kind of whitish
thing another way of asking that
question is did he do any investigations
of what a non monochromatic treatment of
that very complex surface were delivered
in terms of its legibility you sound
like Bob I think that's affected by HIV
last year we did actually we tested a
lot of different things we did look at a
lot of we did a lot of different color
tests we did a lot of different material
tests there was a whole gold period
where this whole thing was gold there
was a silver period it was like
everything there was a blue period it
went through all the different phases
and I think part of the return to the
mana cratic had a little bit to do with
both abstraction and like letting
focusing a little bit on the kind of
forms and part of it was in part the way
the sphere emerged through our research
to becoming more we call the sphere of
the unknown there was as much thinking
less about how much we know of the world
but how much we don't know of the world
so it was in a way meant to be that kind
of absolute in perfect blank and to that
end by even though one could have
constructed a kind of perfect
bathymetric model the Earth's crust
violin kinds of models that exist a lot
of that is a kind of constructed amount
of information it's really based upon a
low resolution thing so the decision to
make that kind of set of pock marks or
something where we wanted that
distinction to be read spatially in a
way and then for this
sort of the finer traces of the lines
that we were focusing on the kinds of
lines of connection the lines of
communication that those would therefore
just be barely noticeable almost like
scratches on the surface so it had a
little bit to do with the intentions of
how we were trying to describe the way
it read and and part of it was also one
of the larger themes throughout was
questioning the way a lot of cartography
is based upon this false land water edge
which doesn't really exist a lot of that
is based upon just techniques of
reproduction you know early printing
presses the ease of drawing a line and
the way that you use say blue versus
yellow or red to say that there's a kind
of land water edge which in a certain
way is very obviously mutable if
anything more to do with you know
precedents of looking at portal in
charts were more interesting for us in a
way as well so I think it sort of
emerged from a lot of those those those
things I don't know if that answers some
of your questions and because there were
three things to there was the globe the
panorama which is very kind of vibrant
and colorful and full of atmosphere and
then the kind of population model below
which was meant to evoke will look more
like a geological feature that's kind of
coming up from the ground the the sphere
wanted to kind of for us at least take a
step back and and not be another it was
large enough as it was but it did want
to also compete as a large figure in
terms of its kind of color in effect
some of the colorful things made it look
like a big Christmas ornament point
there were other analogies as well at
one point we thought that they were
living in the sphere at night coming out
in daytime like that are there other
questions from our guests it's a
spaceship for you Bob next year you can
step into the sphere and take off next
year by the end of my deanship that's
all I'll go
other other questions for joyce and boom
all yes sir I'm curious as to with the I
guess with new or renewed interest in
space exploration as well as the recent
discovery of liquid water on Mars as far
as this research goes how does that
expand kind of what you would consider
earth or Terran if you would and like
does that interest of exploration expand
what you would consider applicable to
this research certainly I think when we
showed the image of we call the site
plan for the world the site plan for the
city it's no longer something that we
see as being earth bond or terrestrial
but rather all that kind of influences
instruments of urbanization the thing
the clothes we wear the phones that
you're using right now probably treat or
text while listening to this lecture all
enabled by things that are even beyond
our atmosphere many many thousands of
miles so I think all of those things
that push push us further and further
out to both explore communicate or
travel are still essentially for us part
of this kind of urban ideal it's
embedded in this DNA of warning to
urbanize to make a city I guess and that
idea the cities for us even larger than
the world itself so I think they're very
much connected but i would say that we
also don't know enough about the world
itself the world we live in and that's
part of the idea behind this fear of the
unknown that while we have mapped the
topography of the moon because we can
see it we actually don't know what's
actually belittle our oceans and I think
that's like six miles below or something
like that and the sort of i mean that
was another thing that we looked at we
were interested in was how we always
seem to want to go out and above and it
sort of associations of going up but
then you know comparing something like
project mo hole it doesn't get quite the
ring that
you know space travel does and and even
though in a certain way what's below our
our fee is actually much more unknown
than a lot that's that's out in the
atmosphere in outer space for being a
geologist in that sense is kind of like
being an astronaut too much lauded
challenge there's a question right I see
a hand behind see the body hi um thank
you for such a lovely lecture I was
curious the 4d and 3d techniques that
you used in your representation seem to
be a part of this larger idea about
expanding our ideas of how to view the
city and surfaces and I was just
wondering when you're archiving this
moment in your research and you're
putting these things in two dimensions
are you going to be thinking about using
these similar innovative techniques in a
two-dimensional format that's a very
good question i mean in a way that we
always are even for something like
today's talk we were trying to figure
out what we would show because the whole
exhibition is upstairs and taking
pictures in the model seems weird and
showing photos of things is kind of
interesting so in a way part of it was
focusing on animations in this case
which sort of pulled apart some of these
things that a lot of people were
wondering out and things that you
couldn't see things that would be
beneath the surface of what's upstairs
and you sort of text a lot of it you
know quoting influences and yeah
absolutely i think where we go from here
or where it goes whether it's in a kind
of print form or ideally certainly
whether it's the Proceedings of the
symposium or seeing how part of this in
in our kind of ideal construct some of
this for us and the symposium was as
much you know started off really as kind
of due diligence for ourselves we just
wanted to know everything about who's
doing what and what they're doing out
there and what their what they were
looking at and what's going on and part
of it was being very excited and
motivated by this kind of unconscious
movement of people in a way who were
interested in many of them know each
other many of them may not I you know
we're excited about the ones where
somehow they're introduced this weekend
through through these events and and so
that's another form that we were
imagining that we were hoping in some
ways that this symposium is the first of
many conversations and it's something
that can take its own life whether
informally and personally amongst the
people or in a more kind of codified way
but the other challenges that you're
talking about more in the architectural
sounds like portfolio eating this
absolutely i mean you know we've we've
never made a website for exactly that
reason because we just don't know what
is a kind of nice website you know in a
way because it's sort of this medium
that you just want to question so i
don't that totally didn't answer your
question in that question down here in
the front very much um there's a very
clear i couldn't think of a better way
with in educational high educational
institution to start a conversation
about what we don't know as opposed to
be revealing certainty about what we
think we know and very clearly i think
there's a polemic visa V the discourse
on the Anthropocene which clearly is one
could say is emerging but also rising
very quickly in scientific circles which
I think will hopefully look back on the
exhibition and also the symposium over
the bet over the next few days as being
a turning point I think for the design
discourses and disciplines towards
understanding how to be able to
specialize that and territorial eyes
that discourse which seems extremely
important to you can you maybe speak
about your early motivations or fears or
let's say hold backs on discourses
related to the Anthropocene and and how
you're potentially opening up the
questions of languages or new categories
by which we need to let's say understand
the discourse from a lot of different
perspectives there I mean I think it's
it's a ways you you are right and
especially because it's such a new
conversation it is something that is
very dangerous because it can be used in
so many different ways and it's you know
used on the one hand or something which
could say that you can do whatever you
want now because you're doing whatever
you want anyways and so it sort of
creates another sense of authority and I
think for us part of that has always
been a larger before we were even sort
of queued in and we still feel like
novices that trying to you know make
sense of the discussions on the end of
racine part of it was always in a more
broad sense which is to say that like
early motivations or pre Anthropocene
were questions of just what would for us
working in architecture what your role
would be in some of these larger
questions like what how do you respond
to this you know what can you do or what
what do you do or are you supposed to do
anything because the more typical
response is to say you know by others we
always have this kind of cartoon of like
in a construction document you sort of
bubble something out and say by others
because it's in the somebody else's
subcontractor does that and I got to
extend its associated for the circle
around the whole world and say by others
because you're usually very content to
focus on something more contained so I
think that was one of our motivations to
just to see also how one can expand the
scope given the context and also I
should add that we're very lucky here to
have Mark Williams who is sitting in the
front row and is on the anthracene
working Commission and is how many
member founding member of it and it'll
be one of the people decide when
deciding on when the Anthropocene
started if it did and if so when so I'm
sure hope the two of you can also talk
and connect and talk about and perhaps
have a more in-depth conversation about
well then I think that precede means
right but i think you know and i
obviously the way we framed the
discussion this weekend was structured
around that and through maybe the
language that we are familiar more
familiar with as architects which was
thinking about it through construction
or terms of construction I mean I know
I'm not we're not fully answering your
question in a way but I think those
those were the motivations in a way some
larger questions of what architecture
does
and to that end I think it was always
for us we didn't see it as something
that was separate from you know the way
we work it seems inherently like a very
speacial problem one that's about
bringing to bear and bringing to light
and materializing things that come
across different interests and bringing
people to a kind of conversation and
trying to find common terms and for us
especially in the exhibition it has to
do with the things that were familiar
with the tools of trade that we're
familiar with which is drawings and
models predominantly and things that are
spatial and visual for obviously the
symposium it was through language and
using terms like you know scaffolding or
excavation or demolition surveys
assemblies and how basically how you can
understand excavation in that case
literally as excavation to find when the
Anthropocene started through these
traces in the soil versus an excavation
that might be more historical or
cultural or in the case of that panel
with Liam young you're looking at
unknown fields and what that might mean
so I mean that was part of what we were
hoping both for the symposium and in the
exhibition to find these kinds of common
languages to explore it that's it
thank you for a remarkable project and
it is so the exhibition itself is so
site-specific have you thought about
what it's going to what it might take to
place it in other places and are you
thinking about doing that we're going to
make a building that looks exactly like
poor Rudolph home I place it there no
actually it's I mean we were incredibly
lucky to have an exhibition here a place
that was very familiar but also proposed
an enormous challenge because we could
actually visit it every day or every
other day and men that we actually could
or have the privilege of having to
respond to very specific things and that
meant that we went back and forth with a
lot of decisions what seemed like a more
clear-cut process initially at what
we're going to do led into more and more
questions in terms of how we laid
everything on but that said I think we
did make everything in a way that they
could travel either discreetly or in
pieces so the sphere could goes one
place the panorama could become its own
room and occupy another place and so on
but i think it's the conversation to
have together that makes it very
interesting so in that sense it has
might be a challenge to find a proper
venue but yeah it was definitely I think
in all summer before it went into the
gallery it was installed in the drawing
studio as too little egg lose half egg
lose you know which obviously is not
great but in another venue it's kind of
interesting almost to see two
hemispheres potentially and or 12 gold
or 12 gore's taken apart or similarly
whether it's the larger model which
obviously is what over 400 little cast
panels that could be seen in isolation
or seen in a different way and the other
components like the panorama drawing
I think to move the exhibit around would
also require a large group of elves it's
not easily transported I someone who
watched it being built Phil you were
talking about the sort of two frames of
reference that you were using to explore
the question this weekend the kind of
the graphical or pictorial and language
but it seems to me that there's a sort
of third dimension and we talked a
little bit about this when you're
putting your latrobe proposal together
that there's a huge amount of sort of
informational infrastructure to this
project and I wondered if you could talk
a little bit about how that was
organized and also I'm wondering whether
that data this enormous sort of treasure
trove you created is going to be
accessible to these architects who are
bubbling out the world and calling it by
others yes that is that that's yeah
there's another whole presentation that
we decided not to give which fills been
privy to which is the sort of data
process side of things and how this is
structured and yeah and that is another
I mean almost related to Maddie's
question you know that's another kind of
format for this which is how in a
certain another conceit of this project
or another framework for this project
was that it was a kind of site analysis
like a goal bull site analysis in some
ways that was available such that any
person who was working on a project who
would never have the kinds of resources
in a small office or another office to
really look at the kind of context of
urbanization or larger urban issues for
their project what it would mean and
everybody's doing these small offices
everywhere working on master plans for
you know hundred thousand million square
feet you know hundred thousand you get
my point and so yeah absolutely that is
another sort of life of the project
after or we always see this more like as
a kind of starting point for the project
or we've always seen each moment as the
next starting point for the next
opportunities and we would certainly
like that to become more accessible in a
way I think the thing that as you know
and the challenges are is it's a very
it's not a kind of integrated tool there
are a lot of wonderful integrated tools
but the way
a this all comes together is
extraordinarily bespoke with lots of
automation involved but totally bespoke
throughout so whether it's calling data
and doing very very manual checks like
one of our sort of anecdotes is like
Saudi Arabia is always wrong because the
way C deck does I Arabia is they have
all of their data across a kind of
regional thing so if you do the standard
data thing for that then Riyadh never
shows up and you know that's not right
so that's always like did we forget to
do a Saudi way but yes we forgot oh look
at saudi arabia there's like pixels
everywhere so there's a lot of that kind
of individual tailoring of looking at
literally you know demography at top 100
cities let's just make sure that they're
there and I'm sure there's thousands and
thousands of you know millions of
mistakes and glitches but I think that's
also reflective of the amount of
information that's out there and that's
one of I think I can't speak of this but
having sort of followed some different
policy discussions about environmental
policy and larger questions of
international governance it's your
transparency of data or standards it
seems to be one of the kind of topics
and inevitably the things that we were
using were things that were publicly
accessible and what we were doing is in
a very poke way with as much as possible
to bring them together so it would be
wonderful for this to become something
that is more part and parcel of a new
project because I think we've gotten
very customed to looking at larger urban
networks and it's still but still for a
conversation like this in a very
regional way right in a very small way
I'm not in a way I think that actually
expands it to what it needs to be about
that doesn't answer a question or kind
of the childhood Phil I think as you
sorry or just one last comment is that
this too much data and we certainly
aren't people who are making data but
we're just interpreting it and filtering
it and I think that's another whole
other kind of game altogether right I
think sorry so upset so did you say
thanks thanks guys for a really
stimulating talk you've done an
incredible amount of work collected and
incredible
data a lot of the modes of
representation and abstraction you
employ in the show upstairs grow out of
a certain intellectual culture of
quantification and certainty but a lot
of your references grow out of a
different intellectual tradition or
different but related in what from
tradition we get Lewis Carroll really
goal by way of Auden by way of nemeroff
I was wondering if you could speak to
the way the types of knowledge pursued
in the humanities have informed your
understanding of the types of
information you pursue in this project
are you calling us humanists I think
absolutely and in many in many ways
those are the references we often start
with or maybe challenge or provoke us
and that's perhaps I we started our
lecture today was to try and identify
for maybe see me or five seemingly
different stories or things or moments
and there many many many more but give
you a glimpse of the kinds of things we
that prompt questions for us and then
allow us to pursue that in a different
way whether it's looking at a blank map
and saying WOW why is that Matt blank
right it kind of suddenly sponsors a
whole series of questions and
investigations that can go down any
number of different ways maybe that
spark I think as you're absolutely right
comes from maybe our mother's milk and
having go into an institution like this
way it's very much grounded in a
humanist tradition and we're drawn to
that kind of I guess thought or process
and that has its burdens but that's what
we know I guess but I think also for us
we always try to gelatin because we find
that it gets rare well I don't know it's
very rare but there seems to be
different trends of things and where we
obviously embrace the generalist
approach and I I think we wouldn't be
able to look at a kind of data drawn
without looking at everything else that
came around it the context of it the
history of it the other the
representational language of it you know
and that was always you know the work
came because you had to do it like you
were compelled to ask that question of
like you know what is the implication of
herb oils has done a drawing like this
or what does it mean to have a line or
not have a line or do something in color
or not
color and for us it was always as much
about these larger narratives very
obviously very interpretive I mean I
think anybody would not necessarily read
a lot of these sources in the way they
are but i think that was again like what
the mall that I think we've always sort
of been products of this literary
liberal arts institution in that way and
always seek ways that it can be very
much part of what we're doing in because
we find that that's vital to everything
that we engage in my Oh diana has a
question wait need a mic it's very good
to see this as a unit in a way I don't
know if you're going to accept the
description but what you have put there
is all our terms of engagement with
youth and I wonder if the fundamental
question is not what are the terms of
engagement that we have to have with at
earth that this is a description of what
we've done it's the past in a way and
then the question the next question is
ok what is what is the terms of
engagement yeah and I don't know if you
accept that no absolutely I mean and
that's actually a that was a kind of
critical existential crisis throughout
every so often every month or so which
was what this project was you know
whether analytic or projective or
speculative and there were different
things that always haunted us in
different ways we can't tell you how
many people would be disappointed when
they heard that we weren't designing a
city for seven billion people because
they expected that this was our project
in some ways I tried to get the
Commission
but then we also got the opposite
reaction where a lot of people received
at the instant they thought you read the
title they assumed it was some kind of
very sort of brash you know cheap
designed that came out of you know a
two-week Charette for you know a city
for seven billion and they were
instantly saying like why would you do
that so it definitely you know we we
definitely at sort of a certain point
accepted that it was it's kind of
ridiculous to imagine that in you know
two years plus four years groundwork
that you would ever feel comfortable to
be descriptive like to be prescriptive
in any other way because you're just
trying to make sense of the problem and
if anything that's what we found was
that there are very few common terms and
just making sense of these and even
something like scale was a huge thing
and again these are sort of
architectural techniques that are so
important which is reconciling what our
standard scales or what does it mean to
work at something at that scale on how
you shift so we very much did bracket
that and part of the impetus to have
this conversation this week and the
symposium was because we wanted to be
able to have the discussion be where
there was somebody or some question of
what it meant you know more in a kind of
projective way and that you know it
didn't quite work that way but at a
certain point the panel's had been
framed where it was you know ideally you
know two people one who was looking at
the term in two different ways breaking
taking it apart you know approaching it
in a different way and one person who
was sort of just whatever they're doing
they're doing something it was doing
like making something or projective
whether they're a designer I you know
that it became just more about the kinds
of conversations that we were hoping to
sponsor but yeah
I think oh now another question for
professor Sanders no here's the mic no
no I was just I assume that Diana being
so interested in her own work and trying
to develop alternative forms of
representation that that was what your
comment was going to be about and and
and and I think another it seems to me
the project is as much about this
amazing analysis to map what we haven't
sort of map before but the extraordinary
sort of representational technique so
you had event indent to do that so I
wonder for another kind of projective
outcome of the project is the
development of representational
techniques that not only you can use but
we all can use and I wonder if you could
speak to that I certainly and we would
start with some basic questions often
like how would you draw a section of the
world which seems ludicrous and simple
at the same time and we found that we
couldn't do it both due to a lack of
knowledge perhaps or there were so many
different theories about what is
actually in can encapsulate sue it's
crossed I was structured and and that
lack of information in some ways was
actually very exciting and thrilling
because it allows you to kind of then
invent or expand the ways you think
about things or even drawing a kind of
elevation of the world again seems
really simple but also incredibly
challenging so those kind of
representational tools or devices if
anything emerge from what seemed like
simple architectural problems or
questions that we at least approach and
that's the weight we carry again we also
had a kind of I mean I think in a way we
we are well even within what we're doing
as architecture we tend to be very
analog in a certain way we're like the
consciousness of scale and what you're
doing at a certain scale was really
important so in the way that there's a
at least within architectural kameez
there's like an easy legibility of what
quarter inch should do versus what 16th
in should do versus 30 you know there's
a lot of conversations about what it
means when you're working at a kind of
you know infinitely scaled environment
and its relationship to other things
which you're always kind of conscious of
as an educator was something that we
looked at instantly so one comparison we
had always wear
many of you know Ben fries road drawings
road maps and just looking at literally
like Michelin or not Michelin whatever
American version of maps are of
Minneapolis or around Detroit and
looking at the Ben Frey ones and the
same road maps that you get when you go
to triple-a and it was incredible how
different was because it was such a kind
of I mean obviously have different
purposes right but those maps were such
it there was such an abstract scale
where you couldn't get a sense of how
big something was in a kind of human
sense of space and then you look at
those road maps and you just could
understand incredibly the scale of a
city or you you could register and so
that was also something that for us was
really important about the
representations was finding a kind of
balance where it was and you know I I'm
not certainly succeeded in this but
where it was something that was
immersive and you could almost find a
way to register something around
yourself in relationship to something
that was global which you don't always
get with a lot of these kinds of maps
and cartography which you know is
something that's very much embedded in
the way we approach architectural
representation I think we put our
speakers to a pretty good bring her here
I they didn't mention one of the most
important criterion bacteria in the
design of the exhibition that's right is
where would the bar be located the earth
as it skits own demands but a bar as its
own special feature at the Yale School
of Architecture so that was the other
design criteria that absolutely it was
not noticed we have a lot of models of
cars yes I felt right the earth could
change its size but the bark or not so
with that
I would ask that we thank our speakers
again and that we go up to the gallery
to see the exhibition although we hard
and with so many people but it will be
there for everyone to see all through
the weekend as a symposium continues and
so I thank our speakers very much for
their presentation
you